Speaker 1: But I will say Trump does have one
thing going for him right now. And that one thing,
of course, is the fact that his poll numbers are
looking better. And there was another new poll
out this week that I want to talk about for just a
minute, because I think it's worth while, because
this is exceptionally creepy. Following the FBI's
execution of the search warrant down there at Mar
a Lago, what Trump calls, of course, the raid.
Donald Trump's favorability among Republicans
increased. Now we know that there's nothing, you
know, surprising about that. But listen to this.
This is according to an NBC News poll as reported
by the Hill. Republicans who support former
President Trump more than they support the GOP
climb to 41% in August, up seven points from May,
when 34% said they supported Trump more than the
party. A slim majority of Republicans are. 50%
say they support the party more than they do,
Trump, the poll finds. But that's down from 58%
in May. So we went from a 24 point gap of
Republicans who said they loved the party
more than they love Trump to. Now, a nine point
gap of Republicans who say they love the party
more than they love Trump. Now think about
what that means for just a moment here. Right.
These are Republican voters. So
outside Republican world, you know,
election applications of this poll don't
really exist. This means. The you have 41%
of Republicans out there based on this poll who
say that my loyalty is not to a political party.
It's not to the Office of the
Government. It is to Donald J. Trump.
That guy. That spends all his time golfing
and complaining about things online.
That's where my loyalty is. I look at him and I
just. Mhm. Right. I see it. I feel it. The power
coming off of that man. That's nuts. And I
think it's time we just say things like that,
right? We just have to come out every now and
then call it what it is and just say, that's nuts.
But that is what today's GOP is. You know, we saw
it with Liz Cheney losing by like 40 points last
week. We see it with the way these Republicans
react any time Donald Trump gets in trouble.
You know, the individuals showing
up and wanting to attack the FBI,
a building filled with people
with extensive firearms training,
and they're like, Oh, yeah, I'm going to take them
all on. Yeah, it didn't end well for any of them,
but that's how much they love Donald
Trump. That's what they're willing to do.
It doesn't matter if it seems crazy to
us. To them, it seems normal. And that's
what we're up against on the other side. And
that is why these people are so dangerous.
We got to take another break. Again, I am Farron
Cousins. You find me on YouTube at YouTube.com
slash fair and balanced YouTube.com. Slash the
ring of Fire, Twitter, Facebook and Instagram at
fair and Balanced. This is The David
Pakman Show. And we'll be right back.